quindi secondo te comunque per fare una
roba così tu che dici
ciao ragazzi bentornati una nuova
puntata di vita buttata il tema della
puntata di oggi è messaggi assurdi prima
di iniziare sarò molto prima di iniziare
sarà pieno di bacilli sono molto sincero
con voi purtroppo ci si è bruciato
l'hard disk quindi questa è la seconda
volta che stiamo facendo questo video in
passato è stato fatto con un ospite
meravigliosa che io inviterò purtroppo
l'ho già chiamata martina scusami
perdonami non so cosa sia successo per
cui alla fine sono riuscito a strappare
a botta di la persona di cui tutti
quanti stanno parlando io sono
contentissimo di ospitare all'interno
degli studios di casa mia
mark caltagirone allora marche grazie
mille per essere qui parliamo di chat
assurde di messaggi strani che hanno
ricevuto le persone futura visto questo
format praticamente io chiedo su
instagram su facebook di mandarmi dei
messaggi vocali e le persone alla fine
mi condividono le loro esperienze
tramite facebook
ok è un ragazzo un po timido si fa
vedere poco in giro ma direi di partire
subito ad ascoltare i messaggi che ci
sono arrivati campo sarà impegnatissimo
tra i preparativi del matrimonio
le interviste dvd la live
partiamo non so se ridere di più per
quello che mi hanno scritto opere il
nome del contatto sinceramente ciccio
spara lesto scrive se letteralmente da
un violento al muro ciccio spara lesto
bah mi sembra in realtà nome e cognome
per quanto riguarda passaporto ctv
francesco e spara lesto e della famiglia
spara lesto come la famiglia caltagirone
cioè famiglie che si vedono ovunque ho
conosciuto questo ragazzo non va
parlavamo ma io non mi ero interessato
le avevo detto e questa è stata la sua
reazione
ok comunque non una come te dice no di
vedersi a me fa ridere sinceramente sono
nettamente più bello di te dovresti
ringraziarmi che te lo chiedo come siamo
ridotti qua allora ti ringrazio ma no ma
io ne ho di meglio di te ma figurati una
come te dovrebbe saltarmi addosso e io
dire no mi vien da ridere parla con loro
allora mi spedì scusami che il mitomane
che ti ha mandato questa cosa cioè come
se uno ti scrivesse ti va di venire a
cena fuori con metodi di ci guardano non
piacere a tanti volevano venire mark
perdonami se cioè non è un pochino come
dire sto insieme a uno e poi non esiste
già scritta che ho legato ai messaggi di
questa persona che mi scrisse diciamo
con superamenti nei a rifarmi bastiamo
no volevo solo dirti che sei così bella
che mi sembri una dea e sarebbe un onore
per me ubbidienti è servirti line
costanzo in tutti i sensi che vuoi
ciao ciao sviluppato desiderio di
illuminazione men che mai una battuta a
testa marche tu sei lui
in che senso era più carino perché se
non c'era le due cose che si
rimbalzavano grazie al cielo registriamo
l'audio separatamente dal video e vorrei
semplicemente il proprio al volo farvi
sentire un estratto di quello che ha
detto martina nella puntata che si è
distrutta e ha deciso che il prossimo
che mi viene una rabbia del genere dico
di sì ciao ciao ospite enrico gianmarco
con tizio a casa mi ha scritto il mio
insultato cioè dei commenti
lei contenzione vacci tu
l'acido vaccino faceto farcito vacci tu
ok ciao
perché simpaticissimo magari ecco tutti
quelli che mi mandano a cagare su
internet forse in realtà solo sono molto
simpatici e non lo capisco è annunciato
a sky per la serie i tentativi di
approccio assolutamente infallibili e
per nulla inquietanti e al comune delle
ultime perle che è arrivato poco tempo
fa da qui scrivono lika piedi cerca
ragazza che lo usi come buccico spicco
regalo per lei se interessata mi
contatti ma molti muri gomma ma bucci si
informa povera non ti non ti ingelosire
solamente una chiacchiera non faccio
domande sulla vostra dell'azione tipo
abbastanza strano ha deciso di adottare
una tecnica dei due mesi la miche
nuovissime con grava dalle carbonare a
te quiero una kippah decisa proprio
punto come poi proprio la faccia da
carbonara grazie a fa perché poi mi
sembri un tipo piuttosto decisa come la
carbonara o mi sbaglio hai vinto tutto
sa qual è il premio per l'originalità ma
che vuol dire la faccia da carbonara
del piatto nel mio viene tipo tondo già
c'è l'epatite che c'è che cosa che
faccia è la faccia di regola carbonari
tipo per esempio per me marca ha la
faccia d'acqua naturale laura ci sono
217 alette laura ci sono 217
marco ciao brucia ospite in via qui
sotto uno dei messaggi vocali più strani
che mi siano mai arrivati ancora visto
interrogando sul suo senso su come
questa signora suppongo sia arrivata a
me certo ma estate io intanto mi tenga
giornata contro frate con christian e
spero che sta tutto vero ti volevo
chiedere visto che socket ai lavori
ancora mar se non li avete ancora i poli
pulcini quelli al collo nudo se per
cortesia non fai sapere grazie al ciao
ciao ciao ciao zio
spero che mi vieni a trovare prima o poi
in 11 anni che abita in questa casa
senza una caduta da un buon rapporto con
l'anzhi ha diciamo solo che forse
inviando il messaggio la persona
sbagliata quei poveri pulcini a collo
nudo sono stati risparmiati
ciao sono italiano coniugato molto
riservato sano mi piacerebbe molto le
carte i piedi se sei interessata mettine
uno fuori dal finestrino poi arrivò non
so altro
ne chiede soldi c'è questa dovrebbe
stare col piede finestrino non certo
punto uno passa vicino e poi scappa un
giorno
già ospite ciao a tutti saluta niente ma
non avevo ricevuto un messaggio lavorate
mi conosce ragazzo che mi dice vorrei
mettere il mio steno tra le teche e far
chiudere
ciao ciao a tutti ma faccio ma il seno
tra le chiappe cioè gemelle contro
gemelli o gemelle tra i gemelli quindi a
incastro
oddio se perverso mark di messaggi
strani me dicevo davvero tanti e da
tempo ha deciso di raccogliere queste
perle in un album su facebook e mimando
mi stai bruciando con le tue foto
i miei fianchi gonfiati guardando il tuo
immagini hai un bel corpo per il sesso
ti darò il trattino tre ore senza stop
del piacere di godere ne manderà in una
foto nuda da te tesoro voglio vedere la
mia pietra e ora vuoi vedere questo è un
poeta una persona veramente veramente
veramente profondamente i suoi fianchi
gonfiati la mia pietra e ora non domani
noi eri se vieni e bari ti ospito starei
ore a guardarti ma cosa c'entrano le
pecore la quiete che elargiscono il tuo
sguardo è bello e rassicurante ma fermi
tutti la crede che elargiscono e questa
è la foto della quiete che elargiscono
io se l'è vedessi morirei molto
probabilmente tu mark è un fantasma se
viene il bove ha ospitato il problema
non è stata la richiesta in sé per sé ma
in modo in cui questo sconosciuto me
l'abbia chiesto trovare totalmente
irragionevole
comunque mia motivazione per non
rinviare quella foto andando avanti ha
quindi fatto inesistenti cominciamo
essere anche fin troppo inquietante e
quindi l'ho bloccato subito brava hai
fatto benissimo comunque posso dire una
cosa queste cose dei piedi a volte
arrivano anche a me non so se anche
altri chiedono mai una foto cose così ho
visto che un sacco di persone si fanno
delle foto con te ultimamente posso
farle vedere ma la domanda è chi è mai
arrivata una richiesta così assurda e
detto sì o no a non aver mai detto ma
sarebbero che se a farlo ragazzi siamo
arrivati alla fine di questo video io
non avrò mai abbastanza parole per
ringraziarti marca caltagirone per
essere venuto qui so che non ti sei
fatto vedere in tv non ti sei fatto
vedere da nessuna parte
e secondo me è la cartina tornasole
della tua umiltà puoi sposare una
showgirl
forse perché proprio gli opposti si
attraggono c'è chi si vuole far vedere
troppo e chi invece non si vede per
niente la pazzesca questa cosa ringrazio
anche voi ragazzi per averci seguiti io
qui sotto vi lascio i profili di marca
caltagirone e che dire fatemi sapere
quali sono stati i messaggi e studi che
avete ricevuto e soprattutto scusatemi
ancora per questo intoppo e c'è stato
con l'hard disk adesso va sostituito
molto probabilmente magari sostituiamo
anche quella hard disk del tuo cervello
e ripeto siamo sempre più vicini al
milione possiamo dirlo basta queste
ansie
ormai c'è un countdown verso il milione
è che dire se vi divertite se vi piace
questa rubrica in particolare
iscrivetevi a questo canale attivate le
notifiche per non perdere i prossimi
video noi ci vediamo con un altro vita
buttata sempre giovedì prossimo alle 14
ciao
il passo di un secondo questo
ragionamento ci facciamo un self in
massa 6 fotogenico da paura come pure io
grazie grazie marca occhio lo spegne le
luci che poi rischiano di andargli
addosso